nobody spot that I saw that uh whatever
you say in Italian for the side of the
chroman in pottery Siviglia spirit or
something man I'm Greg good goryeo and I
am John John Johnny Oh Giovanni Giovanni
three years of high school I don't know
if you guys know this but Martin
Scorsese put out a movie it's called
silence you did take a moment of silence
and that's our review you can subscribe
to day okay so this movie this movie is
about - Jesus priests that's what
they're called right there - Jesuit
priests who Jesuit priests played by
Adam driver and Andrew Garfield
the actor from girls and the actor from
the social network their most famous
roles Liam Neeson the star of
Schindler's List has been taken taken
1800's or something they go to Japan
we're in Japan like Christianity is
outlawed but they're trying to spread
Christianity so it's like taken if Liam
Neeson was the kidnapped person and
instead of shooting everybody in Europe
it's just preaching the gospel to
everyone and you exactly exactly the
same couch tomato in this movie though
it's it's almost three hours long and
yeah it's really captivating it's fairly
slow it takes its time its pace in a way
that takes its time and it's slower than
most Scorsese phones well Scorsese has
done films that move rather slow this
one is definitely not the pacing of like
The Departed or Goodfellas or wolf of
Wall Street
yeah the direction is not very intrusive
in this film now there are some Scorsese
flourishes that you can pick up
throughout but I think you said this out
loud and I was thinking into is it feels
more like a Paul Thomas Anderson movie
the a Scorsese movie and Paul Thomas
Anderson films have always felt like a
slower Scorsese film you're gonna watch
some real life moments yeah I'm not
gonna be a heck ton of dialog this movie
is all about the journey of Andrew
Garfield's character
father Rodriguez made by Andrew Garfield
he plays a man from Portugal and both
Adam driver and Andrew Garfield are
heavily influenced by the teachings that
Liam Neeson passed along about the
Oceana and I remember say Catholicism
but it is Catholicism right there
priests from Italy it's at least
Christianity and I don't know if it's
exactly Catholicism they also relate to
his mission to because you know like I
get the sense at the beginning of the
movie they're coming back from someplace
else they're really out there doing the
Lord's work and you know helping the
converted Maher Scorsese is his Catholic
in real life this isn't a preachy film
necessarily even though it might start
off in a way where you think it might go
down that route of like you know you
gotta be Catholic by the end of this
film it's really not about that it's
strictly it's strictly about the subject
of faith in the faith that they happen
to touch upon his authority anity
watching this film though I couldn't
help but draw comparisons between Andrew
Garfield's work and hacksaw Ridge and
Andrew Garfield's work here because
they're both characters that are being
condemned and challenged by others based
upon their faith yeah you know like it's
all about sticking to their faith you
know having to use that as a tool of
survival the entire time this goes on a
much darker psychological path though as
opposed to what they do in hacksaw Ridge
well cuz I haven't seen hacksaw edge but
this movie silence feels like just a
kind of a rumination on the whole idea
of faith in general because it's easy to
kind of cram a movie like this or to
roll your eyes going in thinking like
it's gonna be super duper preachy and
well it does have moments that do seem
like they are kind of exalting the
Christian message it does sort of look
at the effects of faith religious faith
yeah on all these characters from
various different sides and it paints
this really complicated picture yeah you
know and it also has challenging
questions in there like are you helping
people truly by trying to pass along
your faith or are you imposing and
causing condemnation by like nobody
trying to help out people with faith
because a lot of this like the first
like the first half of it actually dawn
throughout the whole film it really
explores what it's happening to the
Japanese people specific a key time for
for just Japanese culture and stuff you
know why this movie takes place in these
very poor little villages you know on
the coast it deals with the persecution
of you know Christians in that area and
and you know sort of you can use this as
sort of a broad spectrum metaphor for
just about any faith because every faith
persecuted and been persecuted sort of
it something yeah yeah yeah that's
what's so interesting about this movie
for me cuz I feel like this is this is
like what would Jesus do to the furthest
extent of the movie because each
obstacle that they come across in each
new place that they go forces them to
make a different kind of decision and
the whole movie is is really like Andrew
Garfield is struggling with these really
big ideas about faith versus just the
life you're actually living down here
yeah exactly because he's trying to
believe in something higher he's trying
to believe that there's some bigger
miracle surrounding this whole horrible
process that he's going through but he
can't help but be affected by what he's
seen directly in front of him yeah which
are a lot of these Japanese people are
being tortured to death I don't know if
you guys I don't how many you guys grew
up truly religious I grew up we grew up
and we met at Catholic school
we did and I was a pretty devoted
Catholic growing up I know what it's
like to feel the weight of guilt and sin
very head on to have God being very
disappointed in you possibility of going
to help I've had to deal with a lot of
that for many years of my life actually
probably up until I was like 15 or 16
when I started kind of dying then you
know doing it down a little bit dying
hey dying there's these moments where
they're like okay all you have to do to
get away from this is step on you know
the face of Jesus well to the outsider
perspective of someone who hasn't had to
deal with faith I'm sure more people can
probably get their own personal opinions
there be like I don't get why they just
don't do it it's not a big deal but from
growing up Catholic that is something
like even if someone had a gun to me I
would be like I don't know if I could do
that cuz I'm yeah you might kill me and
I might go to hell okay the whole point
yeah is like the true faith even when
faced with death you will not get ray it
and that's a really sort of complicated
issue in this movie you know that we see
from again a bunch of different sides
and that's what makes the sort of
mystery of the whole thing because the
whole movie you're sort of wondering
about Liam Neeson's character and in a
bunch of different ways and I feel like
this is a cool movie that kind of paints
this picture and by the time you get the
answers you were looking for you also
have like a just a human growth journey
wrapped around that so it really earns
at least to me it really earned
everything it is
heard some complaints that it's you know
slow and it's not overly engaging but
this to me
was a really human movie and I feel like
that's what a lot of faith movies are
missing not that this is necessarily a
faith-based movie in the way that we
usually use that terminology but like
this is all about life you know yeah and
people's convictions and what happens to
them and the different ways in which you
are confronted yeah and the strut like
it's really about the struggle to
maintain faith - yeah like the fight to
maintain faith I think it's a great
movie because you find yourself talking
a lot about the subject and the themes
of the film more than like plot points
necessarily will you because this is one
of those movies we're just like one
scene directly kind of leads to the next
one this is one of those movies that
sort of unfolds from one scene to the
next and you really live with Adam
driver Andrew Garfield men just Andrew
Garfield after a while yeah it's I mean
if you want to talk about like film
elements besides subject and theme I
think the whole idea was to provoke
thought from this whole film the whole
idea is to get you thinking and talking
about the subject and feeling is you
could walk out of this going this isn't
the most like thrilling film at times
yeah because it takes its time and slows
down it goes through moments where you
get Andrew Garfield really contemplating
he kind of has this like descending yeah
I want to call like a character arc
where like a character descent he's like
falling apart he he kind of starts
martes me as marta sizing himself kind
of imagined himself to be like a you
know a reincarnated jesus in a way yeah
exactly
watching that progress go it is really
interesting you know yeah but Andrew
Garfield yes he does an amazing job
amazing job and with the way maybe if
you saw hacks already might be going
this is very similar as role in hacksaw
Ridge but as the film progresses it
definitely goes down routes his
character never went through in hacksaw
Ridge he's got an accent he's got it
he's got different accent the other guy
Adam driver I had a harder time getting
past that first yeah I mean because he's
just quiet in the beginning a lot you
know that's not possible for the Ferrera
risked his life to spread out face all
over Japan
it seems to me that our mission here is
more urgent than ever we must go find
father Ferreira it took me time to to
really latch on to both of them honestly
like especially the beginning but you
know the more time we spent with them
both the more I got into them and to be
fair to Andrew Garfield he has all of
the movie to get that done yeah but even
Adam driver you know got me engrossed in
him a night and I did kind of let him
recede into the character after yeah
yeah yeah but the supporting cast is
terrific too and then there and all the
Asian actors are amazing yeah the Asian
actors are fantastic yeah it was really
interesting to see this culture clash
because these people are practicing
Christianity and secrecy that was so
fascinating to see they're like they're
not doing anything like oh there's
clouds in the sky that's God you know
God's really yeah yeah this this is
really just about the mental faith you
know the most like real life movement
regarding faith I've I at least have
ever see a Scorsese's not going out of
his way to say God exists in this world
you know yes please leaving up to you to
decide whether God is real or not and
that and it toes that line really
elegantly cuz things will happen where
you'll find yourself just like anybody
would again it gets you thinking and
feeling cuz you start to think yeah man
give it up and then something will
happen that will bring hope and you'll
be like oh yeah maybe and it does feel
yeah a lot like life yeah but then you
know hey just when all hope is lost here
is something I've done in the nick of
time and uh and leaned out of a two-hour
45-minute million Eason is tacitly not
in this film for that long not in my he
does make a strong impression in this
film hope he's not a forgettable role at
all by telling you what is he does with
his character it would give away plot
points of the film what I have to say
it's like it's so great seeing Liam
Neeson like a true acting role again
yeah that was a tough guy like I'm gonna
kick everyone's ass into believing in
Christ you know it's not kick one
episode he doesn't these are all about
not kicking in fact he gets tortured
pretty terribly and in the
cinematography is excellent like the
landscapes of like especially the Beach
shots anytime they're arriving onto
water because anytime they go onto water
it's like the fishermen they can they
they can't like go to the land and still
I guess are swimming but every time that
happened
now it I just it looks so beautiful it's
one of those haunting dark films that
also looks beautiful at the same time
yeah every what all the shots are really
well composed and everything does look
kind of like a painting and whenever the
camera does move or whenever you know
tricky editing does come in it's always
yeah at the right time and it's always
very deliberate you know it's and the
feel of steer and even though the film
explores a lot of Japan it also is a
very contained film because a lot of the
time these people these people are
practicing the secrecy so they can't go
a lot of places there's a good amount of
time where like Andrew Garfield just has
to stay hidden they're just staying in
the place they're allowed to stay up but
they just stay indoors the whole time
what are they there's prisons and stuff
so everything's very contained at the
same time well yeah you're you're always
sort of contained to the situation at
hand there's none a lot of jumping
around and for a lot of it you're kind
of on either Andrew Garfield or just you
know the people in the scene in a really
intense way you know there's a lot of
clothes stuff because so much of this
movie is in the nuance of the
performances and there's dialogue but
it's sparse
you know and if you guys want violence
like there's some real or some like
different kinds of torture in this film
for sure that I've never seen it's not
like definitely stark it's not
grotesquely violent but it's still very
disturbing because they usually start
with psychological torture you know like
we really want you to not believe so you
gotta say some things that would make
you feel like [ __ ] for saying this step
on Jesus and all that but some of the
torture sequences like kind of wondering
how they shot some of those like when
they're in the water and they're hanging
and then they're like in the middle of
the water that takes are just going like
it looks like they really strapped those
actors to something there's so far but
some of the shots are so far away I
think it looks like it looks like these
actors really had to suffer through a
lot of these scenes it looks real it
looked like those guys just agreed to do
yeah and maybe they you know I can see
you getting something out of that yeah
putting yourself in those shoes as an
actor I yeah and one of my favorite
things best worse AZ films too is how he
edits a lot of his scenes to the use of
music and he's very specific about his
music and there's really not a lot of
music in this film
yeah just slipping off to Boston yeah
yeah some mugging Rolling Stone song he
always plays
yeah you like it three Scorsese but yeah
like when the music when there is music
I mean it's it's always distinct but not
too in-your-face and it it's it doesn't
sound it sounds like people could be
playing this in a village yeah exactly
well even that crazy violin song yeah
yeah like that even sounds like that
could just be someone playing it already
you know and its background well yeah
and even the world too like they you
pointed this out I thought it was great
most movies keep room tone this movie
has just like world tone well yeah here
are things going on outside and like the
sound world is there like early on when
they get to Japan there's when he's
meeting when they fortunately get a bump
into a group of people or secret
Christian believers yeah there's like a
small little Hut the whole time I felt
like it was freezing and then I realized
it cuz of the sound design yeah where
you can slightly hear the ocean waves
outside you could hear the Thunder a
little bit you hear the breeze yeah and
there's and that's what tripped me out
about the sound design so for the lack
of music it makes up in great sound
design for pudding that's what part of
what makes it so immersive is it puts
you in the atmosphere of it all to like
the harsh physical conditions are
suffering in as well this film is a lot
about suffering yeah it's also a lot it
is primarily about faith if you want to
keep it plain and simple but it's really
about the struggle to maintain faith the
complexities and the and uh and the
willingness to try to especially with
Liam Neeson's character the willingness
to try to challenge what you originally
believed to nothing has precedent until
something happens just like he's been
and Sully and like I feel like this is
another movie that that touches that is
making the next most refined choice
right when you're faced with a situation
you didn't have to be faced with before
in it I feel like for those discussions
in this movie it's kind of worth it
whether you're into faith or me yeah
every one every mo even the moments
where they choose to like when the
people decide okay we're gonna step on
Jesus or you know yeah like there's a
there's a cowardly character in here
even in those moments you're like what
does it mean to be scared and what does
it mean to go against your faith you
know if it means survival you know over
death over someone who just doesn't
understand is it okay to do this act so
this this film gets you thinking
especially if you grew up with religion
I feel like if you didn't grow up with a
religion you might not be as into this
film
honestly because yes this film is more
for people that I feel that take some
type of fascination by this subject of
religion well yeah and you kind of gotta
be fascinated by religion and also
sociology because it is about it does
explore all these things from very human
perception and especially the perception
of that time - yeah I think those are
the things to keep in mind going in if
there isn't that sort of built-in
understanding is like you know times
were different this was life and death
to some people this was the key
especially when you know it's it's a
more primitive time there's not as much
tech and access to stuff and medicines
not words out back in the days
yeah people really believed really hard
because there wasn't much else I don't
care if people say there's a slow film I
think that that time this one was
incredibly suspenseful incredibly
intense yeah that times where you're
just like watching the screen I was
never not engrossed in fact when we
started this I was like oh boy this
three hours I probably have to least you
know do some [ __ ] during maybe an hour
which I'll get to Japan yeah and I found
myself just not I'm just agreeing gross
the whole time you know yeah I wasn't
expecting this and I didn't really know
going in but I think this is pretty
terrific I think it's a beautiful one
the best films of 2016 for sure yeah
it's not what I was expecting and I and
I really liked that experience so if you
can get into that definitely yeah it's
definitely eating I think it's - first
Daisy's best honestly all right well if
you you you you are new to the channel
you can subscribe today which was
gracias Senora John his reasons to Jerry
on Twitter and Instagram he's also the
social media manager of facebook.com
slash Blum house and the real rejects
and I want to say to Martin Scorsese is
it's worse AZ or Scorsese or scorsees
Marty sorry yeah
what do you make things weird its verse
ace showgirls
I'm sorry how much I'll come up with it
not weird you why didn't Captain Hook
how did Captain Hook die he wiped his
hands with the wrong hand
ask the wrong hand